Once upon a time, there was a Sea King.
He lived in a splendid palace in the deepest ocean.
He had five daughters.
They were very beautiful mermaids.
But the youngest mermaid, Angella, was the loveliest of them all.
She had a beautiful voice.
Did you see the sky?
Sure, it was fantastic!
Did you hear the voices of humans?
Of course.
It was a little strange but beautiful.
I like to hear about the world above the sea.
I want to go up there and see the sky!
You're still too young!
I'll let you go up there when you turn fifteen.
Humans are very dangerous.
Never go to the surface without my permission!
Dad!
The Little Mermaid waited and waited for her fifteenth birthday.
She spent her time wishing to see the world of humans.
At last, the Little Mermaid's fifteenth birthday came.
Now you can go to the surface.
You'll breathe air and see the sky.
Be careful and keep away from humans.
Yes, dad!